[Music]
20:18 Sony hit another milestone with
PlayStation 500 million consoles sold
across this entire catalog from ps1 days
which is pretty good and like Sony and
PlayStation still strong brand even in
2018 like the ps4 had a great year I
think it still remains the market leader
in terms of sales at least in mine share
and it kind of felt like it's holding on
to that lead pretty well we had pretty
good exclusive this year dying earlier
with God of War
[Music]
I mean like I was expecting it to be a
good game coming from Sony Santa Monica
I did not expect what God of all gave us
though it was like a fundamental
reinvention of a character that people
have kind of written off and it took a
lot of like cinematic leaps and it's
doing interesting things with
storytelling I find it more endearing
now yeah me it's like I wasn't really
interested in Kratos before but now he
much more interesting character with a
more emotional side with the Tres feel
like both of you are missing the point
which is that that axe felt bloody cool
the combat was just so satisfying the
God of War games have never felt good to
me like I love those games but they
never felt intricate or interesting in
any meaningful way was this is the first
time I actually felt good about the
combat and felt like I wanted to unpack
it and figure it out and that axe
element of it is incredible if I can
good it starts off feeling like a
gimmick and then over time the way they
build it into puzzles and the way they
kind of factor into combat it makes it a
proper like it earns this place in their
game
I think they're gonna stick with Norse
mythology for a little while longer
because if you play the end of that game
there's a revelation that's quite you
know a big deal but I'm excited for God
of War and I think more people than ever
have played it and I never expected god
of war to deliver a kind of a story that
sticks with you in characterization that
sticks with you
krei OSes feels like a legit and that
character now and and that is really
trying for people who love that
franchise another big exclusive for the
air spider-man
yes another game that kind of like
unexpectedly good the actual feel of
this game felt way better than I
expected to be I was pleasantly
surprised as someone who loves
spider-man what did you think of it I
loved it I mean for me it was all about
the traversal of the city and a city
felt great as well it's not one of these
big open worlds that just feels a bit
dead it felt like you know the little
people there who fans of spider-man or
they hate spider-man and the combat was
brilliant it just felt so good and
you're constantly changing that and
upgrading Spidey and actually one of the
first things I did was go around
collecting backpacks which you know you
get bogged down with open worlds these
days for the amount you have to collect
and spider-man has a lot of it but I did
love just going everywhere and using it
as an excuse to go sightseeing and
taking pictures of the city and taking
screenshots and changing outfits and I
got so much out of that game aside from
the core sort of story which was also
really good if you think this will be
more than a minor inconvenience gotta go
hey good luck Willy have a feeling
you're gonna need it I think the most
impressive thing about spider-man was
not only did it satisfy the hardcore
comic book fans like you to far more
into superheroes and stuff like that
than I am but I think we probably got an
equal amount out of that game like it
didn't really disappoint like people
were really invested in that franchise
but at the same time as a casual fan
comes spider-man having seen like a
couple at the films and that's about it
I still really enjoyed it and recognized
on to the characters felt invested in
Peter Parker hey MJ what are you doing
here the collectathon stuff really great
on me off for a little while it says a
lot that it was fun because of the
traversal but after a while it kind of
kept introducing new new new
collectibles and I was like so like and
the end of it for me I think it was a
really good game but what's important
about it again like God of War it sets
the stage for more good spider-man games
well those are two big exclusives
there's a bunch more Detroit I thought
Detroit was it may not be the best game
in the world but I thought the
characters were really really
interesting it was a little bit on the
nose with its analogies doesn't think
that it's the biggest like knock against
it yeah it is a bit you know oh that
what if the humans are the bad guys you
know it's what if David what if India
exactly but I I thought it was I thought
it got a little bit ignored or shuffled
under the car unfairly because I think
it was actually a very good video game
another game that I completely forgot
about until just now is its Shadow of
the Colossus remake that was like the
first game Sony released this year I
think I think it was at least in
February or something like that but man
that was a no-frills remake and it was
perfect that's exactly what I wanted
from it I didn't want that's one of
those games where the more you mess with
it the more upset people get and I think
the developers knew it and they were
like let's not touch anything just do a
one-to-one remake and it was perfect
like it rejuvenates that game for entire
new generation of people to you know
kind of enjoy for the first time
there are other games like yuccas a
kilometer again yakuza has been going
under some under some sort of
Renaissance where suddenly everyone
cares about him
yeah and I've been releasing them like
non-stop so good to see cuz like since
the ps2 days has been very much a cult
classic but now since zero everyone
knows that this there's this really
weird cool Japanese exploration game and
it's weird that as Shenmue is making its
return yeah because it becomes
incredibly popular because of you know
it's the spiritual successor almost yeah
it's one of those few games that gets
localized for the West but remains very
Japanese so it's almost like going on
holiday to Tokyo yeah and you feel like
you're you know there yeah I'm glad that
Yakuza is having a good 2018 there's
been a couple of missteps here in there
in terms of gaming one that kind of
really annoyed me was gospel vânia
Requiem see I'm not annoyed yet because
I didn't play those games originally so
but for you who love they win yeah I
mean there's a lot to I don't want to
dwell on it too long because negativity
let's not focus too much on that but is
worth saying like prior to its release
Konami was talking a big game being like
this is not just a simple port it's a
simple port and perhaps is worse than
that it doesn't have any kind of like
the extras is based on a PSP port and
all in all it's like hey hey we're gonna
give you the best version of Symphony of
the Night and Rundle of blood here it is
and then when we got it were like this
is bad my dudes as someone who didn't
get into those games originally it's is
slightly off-putting to know that this
isn't the best way to play it and now
maybe an Xbox 360 is a better way to
play one of those classic PlayStation
game
so one of the other big things this year
for Sonja was VR style of really quiet
in fact it's been quiet from most of the
year but the last few months the very
end tail end of this year it's been
really strong there's a great selection
of games yeah
you've been playing Tetris about that
this effect is a fantastic game as
points say that you don't have to play
that in VR and in fact there's a lot of
advantages to not playing it in VR
because it runs out if you've got a 4k
TVs for a super high resolution it's
really colorful but when you play it in
VR it's a completely different
experience
[Music]
like I was playing originally without
and then Peter Brown who reviewed it for
us was that you've got a try on VR and
he was right like it even if you don't
stick with it because of various reasons
it's one of those things that you should
experience because it kind of it changes
your interaction with it it goes from
being a really cool version of Tetris to
being this kind of strange experience
you're saying we're kind of in it kind
of absorbs the rest of the world around
you and it you create that tunnel vision
that only happens in specific types of
puzzle games you know when you're in the
zone almost
it usually takes you ages to get there
like with this the moment you start
playing the world just kind of envelops
you and you're really really focused and
the music because it's Mizoguchi game
and yeah like they're great at creating
these ambient environments for like no
resolume and is that kind of thing it's
so easy to lose a few hours to that game
I just unwittingly yeah so that's been a
really really strong game for VR I think
but then beyond that is like stuff that
has come out early in the year that is
now getting a second look because of how
cheap is astral baat I played it for the
first time like a couple days ago and I
have been playing it that is an
incredibly good game I played it and it
reminded me of playing Mario and that
means like obviously we know how good
Mario games are an intent it's a
Nintendo quality game from Sony and via
presentations really cool it's like
whimsical and upbeat and the platform is
actually really tight you feel it feels
good to jump around which is the thing
that'd be a lot of struggle with and if
you look at the Astro Boy it'll wave at
you I feel like the problem with it
though is that Sony don't seem to be
making a big enough deal about these
great games that are coming out for the
are it's like quiet quiet quiet
and then like a real gem will come out
like Astro bots and there would just be
no word from Sony about it and it the
almost relying on word of mouth and it's
like there's not enough people out there
with a VR headset to rely on word of
mouth there's enough experiences out
there known to warrant buying one eye I
would personally just recommend it for
like resi seven Tetris effect and Astro
balk and you can pick up some like
Batman stuff on the side as well and a
few other things so in terms of services
it feels like in 2018 Sony's been pretty
much just maintaining more than anything
else
PlayStation Plus how has it been for you
I feel like the quality of games it
seemed like there was a peak yeah we had
that run where that was like black ops 3
destiny to their sex mankind dividers
and like it seemed like the games that
we were getting free with PS Plus was
they were getting to be big titles and
now the last couple months the teams
have dropped off again and obviously
early next year they're going to be
getting rid of ps3 and Vita titles on PS
Plus completely and I don't think
there's going to be an increase in the
number of ps4 games either so hopefully
the caliber of titles will increase to
make up for the lack of quantity it's
never felt like bad value for money yeah
with PS Plus and you're always getting
the discounts yeah and comparing it's
like xbox like I'd never feel like
anything on Xbox is like that amazing
yeah I mean like in terms of the free
games of gold stuff maybe a box isn't as
good but where it kind of makes up for
it is services like you know
the game pass stuff which Sony
technically kind of has an equivalent
over the place they saw but whereas
PlayStation now I feel like is the clear
like it is not doing what game parts is
such a missed opportunity a huge one
speaking of missed opportunities like
taking classic came out this year
oh it's again I was actually gonna get
that for Christmas and then that sat on
my girlfriend actually probably not
worth it like I I'd feel bad if she
spent that much money on a system that I
wouldn't really play a lot cuz there's
only two or three games that I'd maybe
get some fun out of issues with it are
numerous and and have been cataloged in
detail on our site and various other
sites it runs like crap like people
didn't do the work do you know what I
think I could deal with that if the
games on there well yeah word games that
I wanted to play yeah it is a real
misstep it's this doesn't represent that
console to me that is that is not what
the PlayStation was name I don't even
want to play Metal Gear Solid on it and
you I will play Metal Gear Solid on
anything if you gave that to him in a
microwave out player but I don't want to
boot up that thing for it and like same
for Tekken tech and runs like crap it's
not the twisted metal I want anything
like I just it's really really
disappointing and a huge missed
opportunity so inside a bit of a weird
year with events as well III was odd
mediocre yeah it's the the course up was
just for games that were gonna focus on
it was clear that they didn't have much
to show yeah they had these big games
but they don't have much for them and
anything they did show or had
interesting in terms of that release
dates DLC stuff they did it in between
moving people around and not on stream
so like people going to Twitter and
being like oh they've announced the
release date for XYZ but we've got a
flute do you do that is the one good
thing that's on easy you three press
conference gave us actually - it gave us
go sausage humor gameplay yes good a
little bit deaf grounding gameplay but
flute guy was epic
but even after III like Sony seemed to
was just a no-show at so many of them
yeah I think that was kind of like set
the stage for them being like yeah
you've seen loads of our games we build
from Gamescom they build from Paris
games week they cancel PSX yeah they're
not gonna be III next year the Sony's
getting like me when I was at university
probably going on now I might find
myself in my room leaving III 2019 is
probably a huge huge story this year and
mainly because of the impact and the
implications it has on next year right
what does that mean for Sony are they
gonna how do they what do they have
going for next year
I mean a lot of speculation is 2020s
PlayStation yeah
PlayStation 5 the next iteration of it
so like I think a lot of people are
expecting the announcement at the very
least next year surely it's probably
right it's got to because otherwise yeah
there's nothing happening for Sony next
year I mean there's obviously big games
coming out hopefully the last was part 2
or combined actually which is the one
that I'm really excited for I mean I've
got faith in Sony because they're been
really good for us the last few years
like it remains my main console for
paper how much should I pay you will
nothing you doesn't even pay me place
remains my place to play games 2018 has
been a good really good year but it's
just continue to be like in PlayStation
4 overall has been really good for Sony
and for us as gamers and consumers like
it's been easier there's loads of games
the ecosystem has been more welcoming
overall how do you think 2018 has been
for you in terms of PlayStation 4 I'm
really glad we got games like spider-man
and got a 4 and games I've yet to sink
my teeth into like Tetris effect and
Shadow of the Colossus I think for me
this year I think that Sony's actually
had a really good year partly on the
games front like you mentioned but also
I think the most promising thing for me
is that Sony appears to be listening to
its fan base again I wrote last year
about how I thought Sony had become a
little bit too overconfident and we're
starting to ignore its core fan base
whereas now they listened to people
saying they want name changes and
they've they've obviously now arrived
obviously with some caveats but they are
here
and cross-play as well as I think I
think it is a huge thing obviously at
the moment it's only with fortnight but
the fact that you can in some capacity
play on ps4 with someone who's playing
on xbox or on switch I think is huge
yeah I agree I think so he's been a
PlayStation 4 has been really good to us
this year I'm excited for what's coming
I would like to like will say have
concrete dates and that stuff but it's
only a matter of time until we have that
stuff like lot of us go see Tsushima
death stranding those are the kind of
things are making me excited for next
year so yeah good year could have been a
little better sort of name things out
and then 2019 a lot of potential so
oscar has actually been writing a report
card for us and you can find that on
Gamescom over the next few weeks we're
gonna be doing our Year in Review and
best of and most anticipated stuff so
make sure to keep your eyes on games for
the calm where you'll see us take on
Xbox and Nintendo and PC and you can go
to youtube book home for slash games for
to see all the videos around that and
we're gonna go back to being paid off by
Sony
[Music]
[Applause]